you and we are live
all right hi everybody thank you so much
for um staying on and listening to our
live q a
for theme two economics of disease
control
and considerations for public health i
think you all agree that uh we had three
great presentations from dr kai
dr james trowell and dr irfan abraham
all of them are actually live with us at
the moment
and we look forward to uh having a
pretty lively
questions and answered answers and uh
speaking to
to them maybe i'll begin by asking an
open-ended question
which has actually been trending in the
live vlogs
what are some of the lessons learned
from previous pandemics such as sars
in terms of modeling scenarios so
anyone would like to take that one on
i'm happy to uh if i can
get started with that if you like i'm
james trauer um
please go ahead monash university
i mean i think there were a lot of
mistakes made really i mean when you
look back at
sars in 2003 the fact that we didn't
have a coronavirus ready to go at
population scale is pretty incredible
for whatever reason we didn't put in
place the
market incentives to develop that
vaccine and um i think like
sars should have been the real reason uh
sorry the thing that alerted
us to the fact that a coronavirus
pandemic was possible i mean we got
really lucky with stars it could well
have been a pandemic and the fact that
we did not develop a vaccine
at that time is i mean in retrospect
it's pretty staggering
um coronavirus vaccines are very very
difficult to develop
and i believe from my colleagues
in veterinary science and sort of the
one health movement that
um the coronavirus vaccines
have been sort of under investigation
for a number of decades and yet there's
never been
an effective animal coronavirus vaccine
and now we've sort of
been faced with a scramble for a human
chronovirus vaccine and we're
certainly making some good progress and
yet at the same time there's some
concerns around the quality
of the trials that are being put
together to
produce these coronavirus vaccines but i
mean we basically
i think that's one of the biggest things
for me we did not learn a lesson
from sars absolutely thank you
uh dr trail for that answer um
we have also some very key specific
questions
regarding your presentation specifically
james there was actually you had some
very nice data around
fatality rates in section fatality rates
and one of the things that was quite
striking was the excess
death rate uh if you recall can you
speak a little bit about that about how
uh excess death rates in different
cities uh compared to usual
death rates uh correlates with how
modeling accuracy can be uh can be
calculated yeah i'm happy to make some
comments on that and i think it's
something that was very
much part of irfan ibrahim's talk as
well so perhaps he might like to follow
on
after i've made a couple of comments but
um i
yeah i mean i think we've there's no
question we've seen big spikes in all
cause mortality in many countries around
the world and
that is largely attributable to the
direct effects of covert although there
are some other effects that are relevant
as well
in that um the coronavirus
uh mortality i mean
as i think as often ibrahim pointed out
sometimes the mortality attributing it
to coronavirus is somewhat difficult and
there are
deaths that probably are attributable to
it that don't get appropriately
attributed um in that way and some that
are attributable to it but are not
actually a result of it
um so that again there's there's all the
usual sort of data issues
around estimating exactly what effect
there's been but and so i think that
means that looking at all-cause
mortality is a really important way of
gauging
the impact of the pandemic if you just
look at
coronavirus attributable deaths then you
don't get the full picture
the all-cause mortality is a really
important thing to look at in addition
to that
although there are these these sort of
issues around it and there are also
non-covert related impacts of the
pandemic clearly
the the lockdowns themselves are
changing the patterns of mortality
so the lockdowns mean that we have fewer
deaths related to motor vehicle
accidents for example and more deaths
related to suicides presumably that sort
of thing so we see different patterns
and the net effects is again sort of
difficult to really tease out
but i think one of the most important
things that we don't talk about is the
fact that
coronavirus deaths are very strongly
distributed towards people who have very
high all-cause mortality so
as much as we see these spikes in all
cause mortality
we might see some catch-ups later and
there's a phenomenon sometimes referred
to as harvesting where deaths are sort
of brought forward but they're deaths
that might have occurred within the next
six months anyway
um so the people you know people who are
within the last year or two of their
lives
are very much overrepresented in the
coronavirus mortality so it is possible
that we're going to actually see
some sort of compensatory falls in all
cause mortality over the coming
year or two um post these sort of
initial waves of coronavirus
thank you dr trail so please go ahead dr
abraham
would you like to elaborate further on
that james
made several points that i agree with
i would like to just add that the blue
season plays havoc with these
numbers when i look at it globally
we find that on the low end the flu
season can have as low as 290 000 deaths
across the world
and then as high as 610 000 deaths
if you look at the current casualty from
all of coronavirus
it crossed 690 000 a few weeks ago
so when you look at the united states
for instance
you could have as low as 12 000 deaths
by flu and as many as 60 000 deaths
so when you come combine that with the
coronavirus death
there can be a lot of anomalies that are
created
and then the point that james made about
the comorbidities that
when you have cardiovascular problem or
diabetes or
other comorbidities there are a lot of
people
who have died who fall in that category
and and then when you combine that with
older age
so while there is there was a surge in
death in that march to june time frame
and
continues but there are many factors
that add up to that kind of statistics
so we can't
make a one-to-one correlation like that
great thank you dr ibrahim uh now
moving on to dr kai she had a very good
presentation dr kai and we had a lot of
response and a lot of questions
drawn on your presentation
one of the things that you referred to
at the start of the presentation was the
6.6
health healthcare expenditure that china
has spent i think in 2018 i think the
last data you had
so with respect to moving forward
because you did have a lot of emphasis
on the fact that there may be more
awareness of
public health issues in china um
how much more do you think healthcare
expenditure will increase by
in china and is and is there some straw
starting policies
government policies for allocation of
that health care expenditure in china
uh yes uh located chain in the
china last year we see the health care
sector
to annual increase the double digit
increase
however the gdp increase right now is
gradually declining
so we expect the healthcare
healthcare expenditure among the gdp
shares should
increase fairly rapidly reach to like
eight percent or even nine percent when
they maybe
five five to ten years
so should be compared located history in
the
last 80 years china gdp share
has increased from three percent to
right now
6.6 so
that will be changing in the future
considering combining the both
gdp increased rates combining the
healthcare expenditure increased rates
thank you dr kai and a follow-up on that
you had some very nice data around
online versus offline consultation
in healthcare do you think that will
advantage the tier one
uh two or three hospitals in china do
you think that has a bias towards big
cities
or you don't think that has an advantage
or bias towards big cities the online
consultation
uh the online consultation tend to be
the
between the tier three hospital within
the big cities like
shanghai beijing guangzhou link to the
remote area
remote area so that will be because
the experts will be very highly
concentrated in the big hospital in the
big cities
for the remote area they really lack of
the qualified
professionals so the online consulting
really helped to try to
bring these kind of gaps reduce these
kind of gaps
yes fantastic also i think
just an open-ended question to everybody
i think the million-dollar question now
moving forward and i think some of this
was addressed a little bit by
uh keynote speaker uh today
was is the level of immunization that a
population needs
in order to reach herd immunity um any
thoughts
uh on on that from any of our speakers
around that because i think that really
ties into the uh when the vaccine is
going to come out
and and who gets the doses so just an
open-ended question if anyone would like
to um
to answer that from the q a yeah
okay thank you so uh i think we first
have to get a
good handle on the reproductive ratio of
a disease before we start figuring out
at what level herd immunity is going to
occur
and i think that the jury is still out
on what the actual reproductive ratio of
this disease is
i think initially they were thinking it
was lower
until they found the asymptomatic cases
and now they can't quite say where that
value is and
herd immunity is a strong function of
that reproductive ratio
go ahead james
agree with those comments i mean yeah
and there's
been a few trends towards changes in
estimation of the reproduction number or
ratio
um including that early in the epidemic
we took
um estimates of the serial interval from
sars which is the interval between one
person being infected and the person
whom
they in fact being infected and so that
turns out to be shorter than
what we had thought so that has also led
to some changes in
in what we estimate the reproduction
number to be and
there's a formula that can be used to
derive the herd immunity threshold from
the reproduction number and
that is pretty solid formula in the case
of homogeneous mixing if we just assume
that everybody is
equally likely to infect everybody else
and there's no heterogeneous
heterogeneity and contact patterns
then we can calculate pretty quickly
that
from a reproduction number of 2.5 we're
probably going to need about 60 percent
of the population immune to get to her
immunity
and that so that message i think is is a
message that
is pretty prominent in the literature
generally and it's probably
not too far from the mark um
heterogeneity
is probably more likely to lower the
threshold the herd immunity threshold so
it may be that it's only necessary to
have about 40
of the population immune to reach herd
immunity in the presence of
heterogeneity if the most
um if the most susceptible and the most
people with the
greatest risk of transmission are the
people who also get infected
then that heterogeneity can lower the
herd of immunity threshold
but so i think that's one factor that
plays a role but
for me actually the biggest thing that
we should keep in mind
is that her immunity is a threshold of
which disease dies
out but just
reducing the transmissibility or the
the sort of the infectiousness of the
epidemic to some extent
is going to be a huge benefit for
example we're in a stage 4 lockdown
in melbourne here and i am allowed to go
outside of my house after 8 pm
so we've got pretty strong lockdown
measures
and in order to avoid the situation of
ever
having to go through that again you
don't need to be anywhere near her
if you have sort of like you know a 20
of the population immune
through vaccination for example and then
you
down to an extent that you reduce your
contact by another 10 or 20
you're gonna have a pretty manageable
controllable epidemic so i think we've
got to bear in mind that
even getting a sort of a small but
substantial proportion of population
immune
is going to make a big difference to how
hard this thing is to control
wow thank you that sounds very promising
over to you doctor
i'd like to add something from a
different discipline
since i come from the cyber security
area
let me share with you your audience
and a metaphor or an analog to
the analog virus we have called covet 19
with a digital virus and how we protect
so while herd immunity is a good concept
but to get there
the number of deaths that would occur
would be ridiculously high no matter
what the fatality ratio is
if the number is going up north of 40 50
of the population so my recommendation
is that we need to look at this as a
lifestyle virus
and as james mentioned you know when you
have that
stage iv lockdown it gives it
contributes about 20 percent
reduction combined with the
vaccine you you're getting to a very
effective
level but you could also think of it as
creating clusters
of people that spend time together
that know each other's history and the
equivalent of that
in cyber security is called white
listing we white list applications
to avoid the spread of viruses and
critical systems
and so i would like to encourage the
audience to look at
that as a way of operating in clusters
of
people that have uniform behaviors
whose history you know and that way you
can protect yourself from
the larger community because today's
family is still
the number one way of spreading the
virus when
unknowingly someone goes out comes home
and infects everyone because they trust
him
so we have to learn who to trust
that's a very good comment annie
actually it's a very nice segue into my
next question dr abraham for you
that's come into the live blog so given
your background in mathematics
and experience in it do you see a role
in artificial intelligence
and big data and getting more accuracy
with the modeling modeling scenarios
that you presented
in the future absolutely what
we can do is use data analytics
first we need to start learning how to
segment the population
into meaningful clusters and then do the
analysis on those clusters
and then combine it to create an
aggregate model
and this is where artificial
intelligence and data analytics comes in
very handy the other dimension where
data analytics will come
in is looking at the
genetic makeup of the people who are
surviving and who are unfortunately
passing away
and looking for correlations for certain
genetic
markers it's not enough to just
look at age and or just look at the
diseases like cardiovascular or diabetes
we need to see why certain people
even at 102 survive after getting it
and others you know are are dying in
their 40s and 50s so
i believe that if we go a little further
into
the genetic testing of people and then
looking at the patterns of those genetic
markers
relative to the statistics of survival
and depth
we're going to find some very
interesting information
fantastic and now over to dr john kai
during your presentation dr kai you
refer
to the medical qualification within the
physicians in china
uh and there was a disproportion of of
the university qualifications versus
high school so do you think in the
future
uh in terms of pandemic preparedness
what is happening in china in terms of
bringing those
qualifications more do you see any
collaboration within universities
and and other medical institutes
in in terms of pandemic preparedness
thank you the good questions in china
the mainly problem
for we have a really ironical dilemmas
on the one hand we have a huge shortage
of qualified the doctor
professional but on the other hand we
see every year
the medical school graduates they just
give up or go to the clinical
practice they change to work for the for
example for the
pharmaceutical company for the macro
device to be the representative
representative so the
the bottom line problem is in china
the pricing for the macro services still
quite low
so the doctor professionally couldn't
get
the reasonable compensation for beer
doctors
so they have to rely on overusing the
drug over using the material and the
tests to compensate the laws
on the service but we see the policy
change
right now the the government social
health insurance starts on the last few
years
they start to reduce the
the reduce over using the drugs reduce
the the in the distribution
of the distribution channel of the
pharmaceutical
because there are a lot of money stay
there they want to really
reduce the drug price reduce the
material test the price
to switch the money to compensate the
doctor but
right now still this is ongoing ongoing
things we don't know how soon we could
to get the satisfactory results
but i believe still take some time to to
be finally the
position in china it's like most of the
country to be a very reputable
very competitive career for the for
people for
uh for tenants people for highly
encouraging people to want to be a
doctor
so so far not yet yet not yet
fantastic thank you for the answer just
an open-ended question to our uh
speakers uh i think the other thing
that's been really
uh something that's been a lesson
learned within this pandemic
has been some countries have actually
have taken a different approach whether
they have had
more pandemic preparedness such as
countries like taiwan
and singapore from previous experiences
versus other countries where
their medical systems and their
hospitals have been really challenged
in your opinion what are some of the
lessons of the
you know the benefits of the hindsight
so
in terms of pandemic preparedness for
the future what do you think the
countries and governments should do uh
in order to be more
more prepared for the future
let me uh take that i
please go ahead united states uh given
the fact that we have
more fatalities than any other country
on the globe
and yet we are five percent of the
world's population it's
frankly speaking embarrassing where
we are also the country that has made so
many advances in
medical sciences that help the whole
world
but the lesson is very simple we were
asleep at the wheel for way too long
and when i say that we wait
until there is a 0.2
out of i don't remember the exact number
but
there's a certain percentage threshold
for the population
after which we start taking emergency
action we need to start a lot sooner
than that
it shouldn't be based on fatality it
should be based on the infection
spreading
and we by the time we started doing
contact tracing here
it was too late and then we just went
into this lockdown mode which wasn't
really a lockdown because there was so
much leakage
through emergency services people
through the
delivery people and just people having
to go to work
mostly in healthcare that were
continuing to spread the virus
so we have some real challenges about
what we call
t equals zero in a pandemic and that
makes a big difference
if you look at the model countries that
you just listed for us
you're going to find that they started
much sooner than we did
great thank you thank you over to
uh dr trau any comments from your side
in terms of pandemic preparedness for
the future
well yeah i certainly agree with what
erfan just
said um and i'm at risk of spilling over
into
personal opinion i suppose in responding
to this question but i
just feel like one thing that's really
illustrated this pandemic
is how important public institutions are
and
even if you are the most i mean i'm not
but if you are the most
uh sort of economically
neo-liberal-minded person
in the world you would still probably
want to have
enough sort of government um
government-based strength around public
health systems
to protect your markets from the effects
of this pandemic you would i mean that's
sort of a neoliberal way
of phrasing it i suppose but i think it
just more broadly has
indicated how important these public
health institutions are i mean for
example in australia we don't have
any equivalent of the us cdc so as much
as the u.s
has um obviously had shortcomings in its
response
the australia we don't even have any
sort of formal
national mechanism for responding to
public health
infectious disease threats like this um
so we're sort of you know we're behind
just about every other country in the
world in that sense it was sort of
i guess we're lucky that um some of our
lockdown measures paid off and i think
that might be
partly due to our small population and
the fact that we achieved elimination in
a lot of states
so that most of our individual states
have sort of been around that
elimination level and had
not too much trouble but we were just
you know we were scrambling to put
together
a coherent public health response
because
of years of running down the public
uh the public health institutions that
are required to respond to something
like this and that's
to me that's the only response i can
give her sorry if i'm spilling into
personal opinion
no that's that's fine i think that's
definitely uh
true and uh it's been a challenge for
for every country
uh dr john kai any comments from from
your side in terms of
uh you know benefits of hindsight and
how
for the future uh china could be very
prepared
yeah in the future china i'm thinking
the
very important from the beginning of
outbreak the china system
we also we had after that we already
have the data recording system
but how we should uh the share the power
who should make the decisions who should
allow the transparency of data so this
is the things we need the really
improvement
that's the lesson we had in the wooha in
the beginning
because when you find the beginning find
some few data some few spots
you need very quickly make the data
available to the whole
directly to to the system who should the
cdc
because in china don't have the power to
to make the announcements
so these kind of things we should
straight out
fantastic thank you one last question
has come
uh through uh i think we're kind of
closing uh chloe getting close to the
end of the live q a
uh dr abraham one for you you mentioned
the 18 days
from infection to death which was one of
the slides that you presented
uh one of the speak one of the questions
is was this
age-related or other disease
complications corrected
yeah so now this is a very interesting
thing
is that that 18 days is not
a function of age that is actually
based on a lot of their co-morbidities
as well as the fact that
if you look at the way a person
typically
dies from covet they develop
these pneumonia pneumonia-like symptoms
and
it actually isn't real pneumonia and not
like in the bacterial sense of
pneumonia a traditional pneumonia yet
the the way the disease
and the body the way the body fights
that disease
it creates a lot of residue
and that residue in the lungs creates
this
pneumonia-like symptom so
what this 18 days is is an
average of the time that someone
succumbs
to the symptoms of this disease
so it is as soon as 15 days
and as late as 22 some i believe in
wuhan
one person died 37 days after infection
so
there are those outliers and there are
definitely
people who died much sooner than that
but
the weighted average was between 15 and
22 days so i took the midpoint of that
as 18.
right thank you for that one more
question that's come um
i think it's an open question to
everybody uh so we may begin with
dr john kai the question is uh has the
covet 19 pandemic
created new collaboration opportunities
whether within
your country or internationally
so over to dr kai any new collaborative
opportunities
uh yes we definitely need that
corporations we do
see that china wins in the last six
months
china started to really to try to
give the information give the data give
some resource shared among the
international communities also meaning
that china
in the china definitely we have a lot of
cooperation between the different
community
between the different kind of provinces
yeah we do see definitely for the rufa
in the beginning the lack of the
physicians so it's pulling from
everywhere in china
for the thousands the healthcare
professional
into the cuba into the uh yeah
definitely we see a lot of
like cooperation going on
fantastic maybe i'll go next to um
dr trowell james any new collaborative
collaborative opportunities for your lab
well i mean i'm lucky because i'm an
infectious disease modeler i'm probably
the only person in
the well one one of a handful of people
in the entire country who actually have
more opportunities as a consequence of
the pandemic
um than most others i mean i don't like
being stuck
at home and in stage four lockdown but i
guess it has actually opened up some
opportunities for me but
i'm in an incredibly tiny minority i
mean across the whole of society the
pandemic is has obviously had a terrible
effect
on a lot of people because they've died
or lost loved ones
to begin with and then the lockdown
effects i think have had an effect of
um asthma atomizing and fragmenting our
society as a whole
so i think there's no question that has
been a very negative
experience for the whole world and
there's a lot of people out there
suffering a lot
um what remains to be seen i suppose is
as we recover whether there will be
uh a real i think we'll be living in a
different world i don't know how it will
be different exactly
but i i hold out some hope that as we
go through that process of recovery and
everybody's had a chance to sort of
reflect on what's important in life that
we'll build a
uh i guess a society that's a bit more
cohesive and stronger in the coming
years but
um that certainly remains to be seen at
this stage
that's a great comment um james on that
uh dr ibrahim
yes so a couple of collaborations
i would encourage you know we tend to
live
in our little bubbles or in our little
intellectual cocoons by profession
but i have interest in multiple fields
so i see
tremendous correlation i think that
there is a tremendous opportunity for
collaboration
between the biological sciences and the
people who are
doing the modeling work in this field
with
the cyber security community that is
trying to protect critical systems like
industrial control systems from
viruses and some i've written actually
articles on this
about how some of those best practices
could also be applied
in protecting populations from pandemics
then the other collaboration that we
thoroughly need
is with social social scientists who are
talking about designing
new urban systems for the future about
what
a centralized infrastructure does in
creating vulnerabilities in a pandemic
and how we need to build you know smart
communities as opposed to large smart
cities
where you're completely autonomous and
you are
generating employment and you're living
in small clusters
so that if there is a pandemic they can
go into lockdown
from the other clusters and remain safe
and continue to operate and not have to
have these lockdowns across
all the communities so i think the
cybersecurity community and the social
scientist collaboration
with the life sciences is solely needed
that sounds great and it's so
multi-disciplinary dr abraham what you
just referred to as well as of course
james
your comments around society coming
together
i think and humanity coming together i
think those are
a very valid point dr kai you also
mentioned about
uh you know china's challenges with a
big population so
uh look uh at the end of this live q a
we've obviously just gone a little bit
over time
but i really want to thank each of the
speakers
that has joined us in fact dr ibrahim
has actually joined us from us
it's way past his spare time it's over 1
i think 1 30 a.m right now over there so
i really want to
have a special thank you to uh dr ebron
for joining us
live uh and that concludes our um
a live q a uh for uh
this first day of our conference
please join us tomorrow morning
singapore time
10 am for the second day of the
conference
paradigm shift in infectious diseases
lessons from a pandemic
and we look forward to seeing you again
engaged
third theme is diagnostic diagnosis and
innovation
during a pandemic followed by
um viral and therapeutics
theme so with that in mind i'd like to
again
thank you all the speakers and if
there's any final comments from
any of the speakers please go ahead
i'd just like to say thank you very much
for having us
and you know some things are worth
staying up all night for
and this is definitely worth it when i
see 231 people in the audience listening
to me
and it's just a great honor and to hear
the views of
james and dr kai it was a true
pleasure and honor for me thank you to
me too thank you so much
for having us yes thank you for
organizing this event
yeah thank you very much gentlemen thank
you very much all right that concludes
us
and uh have a great evening everyone
thank you bye bye